so
it's 12 noon this is sky news and this
is the scene in the house of commons
live where we're about to get prime
minister's questions uh that will be
followed in
around half an hour's time by the
statement
uh from the chance of the exchequer for
the
one-year spending review in response to
covet crisis as we wait uh for mr
johnson to take his place
we're joined by our political editor
beth rigby and beth probably
not many prizes uh for what they're
likely to talk about
in the house of commons at pmq's
yeah if pm cues is coming up the prime
minister uh and kierstama will
be face to face but the prime minister
is still uh in lockdown he's not
released until
tomorrow so he'll be doing it via zoom
again
and no doubt zakir will want to talk to
the prime minister
all about this tear-in system that's
going to be announced
tomorrow there is growing disquiet
about which tiers which places will be
put into
one senior source told me late last
night
that they would be astonished if any
part of the country was in
tier one the expectation growing
that we're all going to be put into
tiers to all tier three and to put that
into context
before the national lockdown okay
i think they're starting so let's listen
in works today
this is my last day of virtual meetings
uh with ministerial colleagues and
others before i come out of
isolation in addition to my virtual
meetings and duties in this house
i shall have further such meetings later
today
we're now going across to lawrence
robertson in dukesbury loris robertson
thank you mr speaker can the prime
minister guarantee that in any agreement
he reaches with the european union that
british
sovereignty will be protected for the
whole of the united kingdom
and that the uk will exit the
transitional period
on the 31st of december as a whole
prime minister yes yes indeed i
i can make that guarantee uh mr speaker
and uh our position on
uh fish hasn't changed uh we'll
only be able to make progress if the eu
accepts the reality
that uh we must be able to control
access to our waters and it's very
important at this stage
uh to emphasize that the leader of the
opposition the writer will kia strava
you mr speaker today is international
day for the elimination of violence
against women and girls
on average a woman is killed by a man
every three days
in this country it's a shocking
statistic and sadly the pandemic has
made
has seen a significant increase in
domestic abuse i'll join those marking
this day and i'm sure
the whole house would agree we need to
do far more
to end domestic violence
mr speaker the prime minister may
remember that in
august of last year he wrote the forward
to the ministerial
code it says and i quote
there must be no bullying no harassment
no leaking no misuse of taxpayers money
no actual or perceived conflicts of
interest that's five promises
in two sentences how many of those
promises does the prime minister think
his ministers have kept
prime minister well mr speaker i believe
that
the ministers of this government are
working hard and overall doing an
outstanding job
in delivering the people's priorities
and that's what we will continue to do
and i think if he waits
a little bit longer today uh he'll hear
some of the
ways in which this government is going
to be taking this country forward with
uh one of the most ambitious
of investment in infrastructure in uh
our schools our hospitals
for generations and uh if he wants to
make any particular allegations about
uh individual ministers or their conduct
then he's welcome to do so uh
and i'm the floor is here
mr speaker i didn't really hear an
answer there uh so why don't we go
through
these commitments in turn starting with
bullying and harassment
the now former independent adviser on
ministerial standards
concluded that the home secretary's
behavior was
in his words in breach of the
ministerial code
and he said can be described as bullying
which mr speaker means intimidating or
insulting behavior
that makes an individual feel
uncomfortable frightened
less respected or put down
what message does the prime minister
think it sends
that the independent adviser on
standards has resigned
but the home secretary is still imposed
prime minister mr speaker the
the home secretary sir alex's decisions
are entirely a matter for
for him but the home secretary has
apologized for any way in which her
her conduct fell short and frankly mr
speaker i make
no apology uh for sticking up for
standing by
a home secretary who as i said just now
is getting on
with delivering on the people's
priorities putting already six thousand
of the twenty thousand more police
out on the street to fight crime
instituting in the teeth of very
considerable
resistance a new australian style
points-based
uh immigration system she's get she's
getting on
uh with delivering what i think the
people of this country want she's
showing us steely
determination and i think that's
probably why his side continued to bash
her
pierced armor mr speaker the reality is
that any other prime minister
would have fired the home secretary and
any other home secretary would have
resigned
so i think we'll talk that up as one
broken porus
on to the next no leaking
over the summer we saw repeated leaks
about which areas would go into
restrictions
the prime minister's plans to go into a
second national lockdown
were leaked all over the national papers
resulting in a truly chaotic
press conference and we've seen more
leaking
in the last 24 hours this serial leaking
is causing huge anxiety
to millions of people about what's going
to happen next now i know there's
supposed to be an inquiry underway
but can the prime minister tell us is he
any closer to working out
who in his government is leaking this
vital information
prime minister
mr speaker i've already told you uh that
as soon as we have any information about
anybody leaking
we'll bring it to the house but i may
say i think the right honourable
gentleman
uh is is really concentrating on trivia
when what the people of this country
want is to see uh his support
and uh the support of politicians across
the house
uh for the tough measures that we're
putting in uh to defeat
corona bryce he makes various attacks on
uh
i think on my leadership and the and the
handling of them the ministerial code i
take them
a lot more seriously frankly mr speaker
if the
leader of the opposition could explain
uh whether
or why the unright honourable gentleman
the member for islington north is still
a member of the labour party uh you know
does he support
uh his continue the right honourable
member uh for instance north's continued
membership of the labour party yes or no
why does the answer that question
i think i'll just answer the fact that
it actually is
prime minister's questions not leader of
the opposition questions
kirsten reasonable questions
i think i'll make that decision prime
minister and i think
thankfully we've got the same we don't
want to lose it kirsten
uh it was yours
thank you mr speaker the difference of
course is that i'm tackling the
issues in my party he's running away
from the issues in his
and i take it i
take it i take it from his answer
i take it from his answer that he's no
idea who's leaking
from his government so i think we put
that's another one in the no column
moving on perhaps the most serious of
the promises under the code
no misuse of taxpayers money
for weeks i've raised concern about the
government's
spraying taxpayers money on contracts
that don't deliver
the problem mr speaker is even worse
than we thought
this week a cabinet office response
suggests that the government purchased
not 50 million unusable items of
protective equipment
but 180 million and a new report this
morning by the national audit office
identifies a further set of orders
totaling 214 million pounds
for face marks of the nhs that it can't
use
so will the prime minister come clean
how many hundreds of millions of pounds
of taxpayers money has been wasted
on equipment that can't be used
prime minister mr speaker
actually 99.5 to answer his question
uh directly 99.5 of the
ppe the 32 billion items of ppe that
this country has secured uh conformed
entirely to our
uh clinical needs once we checked it and
uh i you know i think of all the lines
of attack the pathetic lines of attack
that we've heard
uh so far this is the the feeblist
because
uh if you remember mr speaker we were
faced with a national pandemic
that on a scale that we hadn't seen
before
and the government was being attacked uh
by the labour party for not moving fast
enough to secure
ppe we i remember the right honourable
gentleman saying
uh that we needed to unblock the
blockages in the system and that we
needed to shift heaven and earth
to get it done that's what he said at
the beginning of the pandemic
uh then he complained uh that we moved
too slow
now he's saying that we moved too fast
he's got to make up his mind
what his attack is here
well it's obvious that either the prime
minister doesn't know how much taxpayers
money has been wasted
or he doesn't care so so far mr speaker
that's bullying harassment leaking and
misuse of taxpayers money
i must say prime minister it's not
looking good so far
so let's press on the next one is no
actual or perceived
conflicts of interest where do i start
on this one mr speaker
week last week we learned that suppliers
with political connections
were 10 times more likely to be awarded
government contracts
this week the sunday times reports that
the health secretary appointed one of
his closest friends
to a key advisory role this friend
also is a major shareholder as it
happens in a firm that specializes in
lobbying the government on behalf of its
clients
and some of those clients have secured
tens of millions of pounds of government
contracts
during the pandemic was the prime
minister aware
of this apparent conflict of interest
prime minister mr
mr speaker and so far is there any
conflicts of interest
there will be evidence from the
publication of all the details of all
the
of all the contracts and again he just
seems to be attacking the government for
shifting heaven and earth as we did to
get the
medicines to get the ppe to get the
equipment to get the treatments that
this country
needed and what it reveals really is a
deep underlying
labor hatred of the private sector and
it's actually
thanks to the private sector and uh
government working with the private
sector
that the uk was able to produce the
world's first
usable treatment for the disease in
dexamethasone
uh the uh the world's first uh and has
worked hard to pro
to secure a huge numbers uh of doses of
the world's
first usable room temperature vaccine
that's the private sector
working to deliver for the people of
this country and it's common sense
conservative government working with the
private sector rather than
abominating them and uh and and relying
exclusively on some
deranged form of state control how else
does he think we could possibly have
done it
no one's knocking the private sector the
government's knocking a taxpayer
and that's not trivial so mr speaker i
think it's a clean
sweep bullying harassment leaking
wasting public money
and obvious conflicts of interest it's
the same
old story one rule for the british
public
another for the prime minister and his
friends
just look at the contrast between his
attitude to spraying public money
at contracts that don't deliver and his
attitude to
pay rises for the key workers who kept
the country going during this pandemic
if you've got a hotline to ministers you
get a plank check
but if you're on the front line tackling
covid you're picking up the bill
so will the prime minister finally get
his priorities right
stop wasting taxpayers money and give
police officers
firefighters care workers and other key
workers
the pay rise they so obviously deserve
prime minister mr speaker it's this
party and this government
that has given uh key workers public
sector workers
above inflation pay rises this year as
he knows
uh for uh for police for the army
uh for uh for nurses are now getting
12.6 percent more
uh than they were three years ago and it
is this government and that will
continue
uh to increase the living wages he uh
will discover
if you just contain his impatience just
for a for a few minutes indeed
it's this government uh that is uh that
has not only delivered free school meals
and
uh fast increase in uh in spending on
development around the world but has
looked after the poorest in the knees
and one of the most
important facts about the coronavirus
package the 200 billion pound
package of support that the chancellor
has devised for live
lives and livelihoods across the country
is the benefits
for overwhelmingly uh give
overwhelmingly prioritize
the poorest and easiest in the country
and the reason we can do that
is because we have a government that
understands how to run a strong
economy and to make sure and make sure
that it takes the tough
decisions now that it will allow our
economy
to bounce back and that's what this
government is doing
laura trott thank you mr speaker can i
welcome the promise increase in
education funding i look forward to
hearing the detail this afternoon
can i ask the prime minister that some
of this money is spent on school
building repairs particularly for
voluntary controlled
multi-academy trusts such as orchards
academy and west kingstown in my own
constituency
these types of schools were unable to
apply for the most recent round of
funding
and are in urgent need of repair
prime minister yes indeed mr speaker and
uh
that's why we've allocated an additional
560 million pounds this year for
essential maintenance and upgrades in
the school estate uh on top of more than
uh 1.4 billion
and uh in kent uh 20 million pounds
is going to uh kent local authority
including west kings down in church
being a primary school
and uh nearly six million uh to keminol
academy's trust
uh mr speaker and i would encourage uh
my honorable friend to continue
her excellent campaign let's head up to
scotland with leader of the smp
ian blackford ian blackford
uh thank you mr speaker protecting the
foreign aid budget has long been a
source of unity and agreement across
this house and indeed across the four
nations of
the united kingdom in the last general
election every major party
recommitted to that moral mission of
helping the world's poorest and most
vulnerable
indeed a senior government minister said
that
and i quote paved the way for britain to
meet the u.n
target of spending 0.7 of national
income and aid
and that remains our commitment does the
prime minister agree with that senior
government minister
prime minister
speaker listening to uh members
opposites
talking about the uh the point seven
you'd think that they didn't they'd
invented it it was the conservative
government that
uh that instituted and i think this
country can be incredibly proud
of what we have delivered for the
poorest and neediest people
in the world that will continue where
one of the uh on any view
with this country is one of the biggest
uh investors over or
uh donors uh overseas in in all its
forms i think with the second biggest in
the g7 on any
on any view uh in in whether in
percentage terms or in
in cash terms and that will continue we
we have we have a we've seen a massive
increase as the house will know in
uh spending on our on on on our
collective
overseas commitments and by the way uh
the right donald trump will know
that is a huge benefit also uh to
scotland
where east kilbride uh there are people
who do a fantastic job
in uh in development overseas returning
to scotland
in blackford
thank you mr speaker i'm glad that the
prime minister seemed to
agree with the court because the words i
quoted were his is exactly what he told
the house of commons
less than six months ago and i can take
it that the briefing that's going on
won't be true that the point seven
percent will remain in place and mr
speaker we need to recognize that
the covert 19 is a global pandemic and
whilst we're all in the same storm
some nations have better life rafts the
world bank estimate that the pandemic
will push
an estimated 88 to 150 million people
into extreme poverty in the world's
poorest countries
hunger and cases of malaria are rising
and the un projects that as many as 11
million girls
may never return to education after
school closes the uk government
cannot eradicate the threat of covert 19
if there is still a threat around the
world
so does the prime minister agree with me
that keeping the
commitment of 0.7 is not only the right
thing to do morally
but it is the sensible thing to do in
helping
with the eradication of covert 19.
prime minister
of course i i agree that uh the uk
should be playing a leading role in
eradicating kobit 19 around the world
and that's why
one of the wonderful features of the uh
oxford astrazeneca vaccine if it uh is
approved is that
uh it's going to be sold at cost uh
around auto partners around the world i
wonder
i wonder how whether he knows quite how
much the uk has already given
uh to kovacs to the global vaccine
alliance i can tell him it's it's more
than virtually any other country
in the world that we should be proud in
this country of what we're doing
i think about 800 million dollars to
support kobach's
to say nothing of what we're doing with
uh with guardians and sepia and other
organizations we are in the lead in uh
promoting not just
inventing vaccines but in making sure
the poorest and neediest around the
world
get those vaccines i think the people in
this country should be very proud
of what they're doing let's head up to
burton with
kate griffiths kate griffiths
thank you mr speaker i welcome the prime
minister's pledge in the 10-point plan
to plant 30
000 hectares of trees a year by 2025
farmers will play a crucial role in
meeting this target
what financial incentives will be
available to encourage them to make this
long-term commitment
prime minister
my own friend is dead right and uh what
we're going to do is
is use the new freedoms we have after
leaving the common agricultural
uh policy to support farmers to beautify
the
the landscape to make it uh less prone
to
flooding and we're putting 640 million
pounds
from the nature of a climate fund uh
into helping to support the planting of
000 hectares of trees by 2025
every year by 2025. davey
three weeks ago i asked the prime
minister to support
unpaid carers who were facing extreme
hardship during covid
by raising cares allowance by 20 pounds
a week
it's very disappointing that the
ministers haven't found that money for
carers
but have found hundreds of millions for
contracts
handed out to conservative party cronies
mr speaker it's carers rights day
tomorrow
so can i ask the prime minister again
will he either
raise carriers allowance by 20 pounds a
week as liberal democrats are
campaigning for
or will he explain why conservatives
think unpaid carers
don't deserve extra help prime minister
well mr speaker i'll be happy to uh to
look at that specific
uh grant again but i have to say that uh
you you look at what we've done so far
with
uh supporting universal uh credit uh
and the substantial increases in
uh in in the living wage uh we're doing
our best to support
uh families uh who are the neediest
across the whole of the uk and
as i say one of the stunning feat one of
the most remarkable features
of the package that uh we've given to
support lives and livelihoods is
is that the benefits do fall uh
disproportionately and quite rightly
uh on the on the poorest and the
neediest
thank you mr speaker i'm sure like me
the prime minister welcomes the
incredibly valuable contribution of our
essential workers
in keeping our society moving our
economy returning and keeping us safe
but we know that many of our
constituents are facing challenges
through covid
so on that note does the prime minister
agree with me and many colleagues
that as we are having intense
discussions on how to balance the
nation's finances that now is not the
time for an mp's pay rise
prime minister yes mr speaker i
i do agree with that and that's why
we've frozen uh ministerial salaries
this year
uh as indeed they've been frozen by
successive conservative governments
uh since since 2010 and uh i i know that
uh ipsa will have heard
uh my honourable friend and uh i'd
encourage uh them not to proceed
let's go over to northern ireland with
stephen ferry
steven thank you mr speaker at the the
northern ireland business community is
extremely concerned that
it is now impossible to be ready to
fully implement
the protocol from the first of january
their top priority
is to ask the eu for an adjustment or
grace period
this request is based on respect for
their protocol and is not
about an extension to the transition
period will the prime minister give his
support
to this ask prime minister
mr speaker of course we're not going to
extend the transition period but we want
to make practical arrangements to help
uh businesses in in northern ireland and
we've agreed for instance a one-year
adjustment period so there's no uh
disruption to the to the flow of
medicines and we've already launched a
200 million
trader support uh service to uh to help
agri-food
uh businesses and others and that's
going to more details will be
announced shortly mr speaker thank you
mr speaker flood risk from
new development is a key concern for
many of my constituents highlighted by a
case in ickford
where developers promised that flood
risk would be a once in a hundred
year eventuality yet the village has
flooded
three times this year alone with that in
mind will my
right honourable friend commit to
seriously beefing up
the way flood risk is assessed and
treated as part of the planning process
prime minister well i have the
deep sympathy mr speaker for his
constituency
in ixford and the flooding they've
talked but i know i i know it could
what i can say is it's very important
that local authorities do
follow the rules in uh making their
their planning decisions
i'm sure he would uh agree and uh we're
making a huge
5.2 billion pound investment in blood
defenses uh to protect
uh the the three hundred thousand homes
that are at risk
across the country mr speaker
the greater manchester metrolink tram
system cuts carbon emissions
improves air quality and reduces
congestion on our roads
as part of the post covered recovery
plan will the prime minister commit
funding to extend the tram network from
east didsbury
to stockport town centre in order to
improve access
and give much needed support to
businesses and communities in my
constituency
prime minister i'm grateful to the
honourable general i will study the
uh the plan he proposes with care uh
though i should tell him that there is
already
a a massive infrastructure program uh
uh underway already and it may be that
is uh
as the chancellor will shortly announce
and it may be that uh
in due time uh the scheme he proposes
could benefit
uh from those investments let's head to
romford
with andrew rosner andrew rottenberg
thank you mr speaker with the london
area potentially entering stricter
tier 3 or tier 2 lockdown measures
and the devastating consequences this
will have to bring on jobs
livelihoods businesses and indeed the
effects on physical and mental health
as the prime minister is committed to
following the evidence
we agree to a full public cost-benefit
analysis
on its impact on our economy and public
health
before he introduces anything that will
lead to years of economic harm
that could end up being worse on
people's lives
than the virus itself minister
yeah yes i have a high regard for my
honorable friend and he's right to call
attention to the
the dangers and the damage that uh
lockdowns can
can do uh of course they have to be
weighed against the
the damage to to health that's caused by
a wave of corona
virus that drives out all other patients
from our hospitals and
uh and and and affects uh the health of
non-coveted patients
as well so so very badly we will of
course be setting out
a uh an analysis of the health economic
and and social impacts of the of the
tiered
approach and and the data uh that
supports the
the tiering decisions as we have done uh
in the past
thank you mr speaker when 72 londoners
burned to death
at grenfell because of a cladding defect
we all said
never again but for hundreds of
thousands the living nightmare of waking
watch and the non-existent
ews one form continues so will the prime
minister
commit that no leaseholder anywhere
should foot the bill for what's no fault
of their own and make good on the 2017
clg secretary's promise
to end this neo-feudal absurdity of a
tenure
once and for all prime minister
well uh mr speaker she's right
to uh call attention to uh
the the difficulties that many people
are facing because of the ews one form
and i sympathize very much with
uh with them uh the mortgage
uh companies should realize that they
are not necessary
uh for uh buildings under under 18
meters and it's absolutely vital that
they
understand that uh whilst we get on with
the work of removing cladding
uh from all the buildings uh we can and
that's what that's what this government
is continuing to do
brilliant thank you mr speaker
i welcome plans for a green industrial
revolution particularly commitments to
public transport but delivering
sustainable royal bus services has
always been a challenge
but in my constituency south pennine
community transport
is trialling a new low-cost low-carbon
bus service that we believe
could be a model to transform royal bus
services across the uk
so would my right honourable friend meet
with me and south pennine director kevin
carr
to discuss this model and look at how
some of the government's five billion
commitment to buses can be used to
transform rural services
prime minister well she's asking an
excellent question
and uh we are developing a national bus
strategy
uh that will uh look at the the needs of
uh how to get more people to to use our
our buses and and in addition to uh
championing green uh zero carbon low
carbon
buses uh we're providing 20 million
pounds for a rural
mobility fund to uh to support demand
in in rural areas
thank you mr speaker food bank use in my
constituency has been increasing
steadily as working families including
public sector key workers
struggle to make ends meet can the prime
minister therefore tell us
whether he thinks the median pay of
teaching assistance of just
under fourteen thousand pounds and
nursing auxiliaries
of eighteen thousand pounds is enough to
live on
and i'll ask the prime minister again
instead of delivering
a public sector pay freeze later today
will he instead give these
key workers a well-deserved pay rise
prime minister she she's right to value
uh key workers and the amazing job that
they do particularly teachers and
teaching
assistants and they've done a fantastic
uh work in getting our
our kids back into into school over uh
the last few
few months and they continue to to do an
amazing job and i'm proud actually of
the
uh the work we've done not just to
increase uh public sector pay
uh with inflation busting uh package uh
july and july for the third year running
but also for what we're doing to
support the increases record increases
in the living wage delivered mr speaker
by a conservative government
invented by a conservative government
because conservative governments can do
these things
because we understand how to run a
strong economy
you mr speaker lingard has one of the
highest populations of veterans in our
country and as such can i warmly welcome
the recent announcement to boost funding
for our armed forces
does the prime minister agree that one
of the best ways in which we can help
our veterans is to encourage employers
to hire a hero
minister
absolutely mr speaker and i i thank uh
the my honourable friend for the
campaigns that he's running to support
veterans and we support uh schemes such
as that run by
uh jerry hill and his team at hara hero
and we are encouraging businesses to
hire veterans with a new
national insurance tax break for
businesses that do so
and of course making it easier for
veterans to join
the civil service thank you mr speaker
bio yorkshire will place york at the
heart of the global bioscience economy
it will cut carbon by 2 800 kilotons
create 4 000 green collar jobs upskill
000 workers and return 5 billion pounds
to the treasury
the government are supportive but a
delaying investment until at least the
devolution deal
unemployment in york is soaring we need
this investment now
will he start the recovery by investing
in bio yorkshire
rachel prime minister
mr speaker as she knows the government
is committed to the
10-point plan for a green industrial
revolution uh which will
generate 250 000 jobs across the country
uh just in the immediate term i hope
very much that bio yorkshire will be
amongst
the beneficiaries and i can't see any
reason why it should not
thank you mr speaker the news of the
kovid vaccine is great
for both my constituents in wimbledon
and across the country
but i believe when my constituents get
sick they should have the right to the
highest quality access to healthcare
and the plans to improve and invest in
saint helio hospital would do just that
but the premise to work with me to
ensure that those plans are brought
forward as quickly as possible
despite the opposition from local labour
politicians
minister uh yes indeed mr speaker and
how typical of labor
uh our politicians locally to oppose uh
what they call for uh nationally
uh i'm proud that we're going ahead with
a brand new state of the art hospital
uh that's gonna be built in in sutton uh
and
uh the and with most services staying
put into modernized
uh uh buildings at epsilon and sahelia
the new hospital will come as part of
the government's commitment as i say
to build 48 hospitals by 2030 in the
biggest
hospital building program of a
generation let's head to the goal with
tony ron antoniazzi
tony antonia thank you mr speaker thank
you mr speaker
in the summer we stood on our doorsteps
and clapped for all of our key workers
today they will be hit once again with a
real terms pay cuts to their wages by
the chancellor's pay freeze
no mr speaker i really do wonder does
the prime minister
actually realize that claps don't pay
the bills
prime minister mrs pico
i think the honourable lady would
recognize that at a time when
uh the private sector when the the uk
economy has been so badly hit when
uh private sector workers have seen
falls in their incomes it is right
that uh we should be responsible in our
approach uh to public finances and
that's what we're going to be but
be in no doubt that the commitments that
we have made have been outstanding so
far
uh above inflation uh increases for
public sector
workers just in uh in july 12.6
increase for nurses over the last uh
three years biggest ever increase
in uh the living wage and more to come
in just a minute if she'll contain
herself richard
uh mr speaker last month year six
students at the edward peak church of
england middle school in biggleswade
wrote to me about the impact of lockdown
and their ideas for promoting
a healthier planet including encouraging
people not to put waste into the sea
planting more trees and building more
electric cars making more nature
reserves and cleaning up the waterways
encouraging more
elect local electricity production and
reducing air pollution so children can
see the stars
so will the prime minister join me in
thanking the students and their teacher
miss twitchit
and tell the house if their ideas can
play a part in his green plan
yeah right minister well it's quite
uncanny to mr speaker it's as though
mrs twitchit and their and her class
were standing over my
shoulder as i wrote the the ten point
plan and i thank them for
uh their telepathic inspiration uh
it's uh i i passionately agree this is
the right way forward for
our country it's gonna mobilize uh about
12 billion pounds of government
investment about possibly three times
more uh from the private sector
and as i say create 250 000 300 000
jobs it's a fantastic way forward for
our country don't trick it
i'm sure that the prime minister will
share
the pleasure which all the others have
in the great engineering skills which
are displayed in our country especially
in the north
and that one of the great jewels in the
climb the crown are the engineers at
rolls-royce
but is he aware that rolls-royce are
about to out offshore 350
jobs for the north of england that will
be a devastating blow to that part of
the country and remove part of our
national industrial infrastructure does
he agree that the campaign of the
workforce is in the national interest to
retain those jobs in our country
and finally we'll use everything in his
power to ensure that that offshoring
does not take place
prime minister can i just say to the
right honourable to the honourable
german he's so right to
support rolls royce one of the the great
uh
companies in our country and uh we want
to make sure
obviously roles is suffering at the
moment from the problems in the
aerospace
sector the uh the fact that no one is
flying
uh when you make a lot of your uh your
money from servicing
uh aero engines as as rolls royce does
it's it's a very difficult time
at the moment we're keen to work with
roles to ensure that that
rolls royce to ensure that company has a
long-term future
uh as a great great british company and
uh
he's making an excellent point and i can
assure him that the government
is on it speaker i'm aware there are
obviously no perfect options at the
moment but can i raise the prime
minister the issue of
pubs and bars who will be affected by
the tier 2 restrictions
many of these such as yorkshire rails in
snaith in my constituency have invested
considerable amounts of money into being
curved secure
and they will now be denied access to
their valuable uh christmas
uh pre-christmas trade can the prime
minister look again at those t2
restrictions and if not look at what
other financial support
can be offered to those bars and
restaurants that cannot offer a
substantial food
uh offering during this period prime
minister
uh the my my right on my honourable
friend is completely right about
uh the need to uh support uh local
business and particularly in the
hospitality sector and
uh he should know that in addition to
the 3 000 pounds
uh grant for businesses that are forced
to close we've got another
uh a grant of two thousand one hundred
uh
pounds uh uh per month for businesses
that uh
uh in the hospitality and accommodation
hospitality accommodation
sector that's on top of the uh the
support that we've given
via via furlough obviously and
uh via business rates uh and uh
and uh and the cuts in vat which are
obviously intended to support
uh the hospitality sector as well i am
keenly aware of how
difficult it is for those pubs bars
restaurants hotels
that are facing uh we'll face a tough
time
in in the tears as we come out uh next
week
uh we will do our level best to support
them i should say we're also giving uh
1.1 billion to
uh to local councils to to help them
support businesses
that are facing difficulties but i just
want to say one thing to the to the
house
as we come out of the of the of the
lockdown
the way forward is not just through the
the vaccine which we hope
we will be able to start rolling out in
the course of the next few weeks and
uh and months but it's also the this
prospect of
mass community testing and i want to pay
tribute to the people
of liverpool uh who have really stepped
up
and uh in huge numbers tens hundreds of
thousands of people in liverpool
have been tested and that seems to have
helped
to drive the virus down in
in liverpool and we want to see uh that
type of uh collective action uh
stepping up to to squeeze the disease uh
happening
across the country so and and that i
think is the
is a a real way forward uh that will
enable the
uh the re the hospitality accommodation
uh hotel sector uh to come out
of uh these restrictive measures uh
quicker
than uh than than has been uh
currently recently possible we were
facing we've got two new
uh very very important scientific
developments to answer the question
prime minister
i'm very pleased that the house of
commons has been able to help deliver an
improvement
to the sound and vision from number 10
today
but we'd like our kickback this
afternoon prime minister
right in order to allow the safe exit
vulnerable members participating in this
item of business
and the safer rival and those
participating in the next
i'm suspending the house for three
minutes order
that uh brings uh prime minister's
questions to a conclusion now a change
over before the
uh spending review statement by the
chancellor
in that session of prime minister's
questions uh kirsten the leader of the
opposition went on
uh the ministerial code and particular
boris johnson's introduction to it
saying that on bullying
harassment leaking the award of
contracts
and conflicts of interests uh
ministers had broken the rules uh mr
johnson replied to that by saying
it was trivia the leader of the scottish
nationalists
asked questions about the cut in
britain's foreign aid budget which we
expect to be announced by the chancellor
let's bring in
our political editor beth rigby
uh so a uh far-reaching bill of
indictment there from
the leader of the opposition
yes adam some exchanges there on pretty
patel that incident
uh breaking at the last end at the end
of last week
the prime minister decided that she did
not break the ministerial
code even though his independent adviser
on the ministerial code decided that she
had
and it was his independent adviser sir
alex that was
uh the one to resign not pretty
patel who retained her job and sarkis
stalmer pulling the prime minister
up on that asking him a number of
questions on that
mr johnson defended pretty patel he said
i make no apology for sticking up or
standing by the home secretary
uh sir kirstarma replied that any other
prime minister would have sacked the
home secretary
and any other home secretary would have
resigned
we know that boris johnson likes to go
on the attack when he's in a defensive
position and then he tried to criticize
uh circus stammer over the jeremy corbyn
uh row going on at the moment uh jeremy
corbyn having the whip withdrawn
from uh by circus dama amid
the continual row between uh the party
and jeremy corbyn over
anti-semitism um and the prime minister
uh asked him about that and he got a
rebuke didn't he there from the leader
of the house telling the prime minister
uh that this is not
um lead of the opposition questions this
is prime minister's questions
uh and trying to stop the prime minister
uh trying to quiz
sir kirsten when he didn't much fancy
answering the question put to him
so that was all the politics around
pretty patel but also
interesting to honor something we're
about to find out
about the public sector pay freeze uh
the prime minister asked repeatedly
about a public sector pay freeze uh he
said you'd have to wait to the spending
review he sidestepped whether or not
that pay freeze which we expect
is going to be announced by his
chancellor
uh instead listing um this year's public
sector pay rises and saying that there
will be a living wage
increase in the spending review but
millions of people will be watching
carefully to see whether they're going
to get a real terms pay cut
uh when the prime minister sorry when
the chancellor uh moves to the spending
review so
in terms of spending cuts we're looking
for that and also of course
the foreign aid budget the overseas aid
budget will they cut it from 0.7
to 0.5 that would save the chancellor 4
billion pounds
in spending and to put that into context
what is he looking to spend
more money on in this spending review
it's a one-year review not a three-year
review
he doesn't want to look too far into the
future when
the economic outlook is still so
uncertain because of covid
the recession and the hope's recovery if
that vaccine
kicks in in earnest early next year but
he's looking at spending 4.3 billion on
a jobs program that we're going to hear
about today
an additional 3 billion to on the nhs so
a chancellor that will stress that there
is no return to austerity spending
is increasing but also i think watch for
the nod
uh towards uh responsible uh fiscal
management going
into the future further into the future
to the house of commons where the
chancellor rishi sunak
is about to set out his uh one-year
spending review
in a time of coverage i'd like to point
out that the british sign language
interpretation of the statement is
available
to watch on the parliamentary live dot
tv
i now call the chancellor of the
exchequer to make a statement chancellor
[Applause]
mr speaker today's spending review
delivers on the priorities
of the british people our health
emergency
is not yet over and our economic
has only just begun
so our immediate priority is to protect
people's lives and livelihoods
but today's spending review also
delivers stronger public services
paying for new hospitals better schools
and safer streets and it delivers a
once in a generation investment in
infrastructure
creating jobs growing the economy
increasing pride in the places we call
home
mr speaker our immediate priority is to
protect people's lives and livelihoods
so let me begin by updating the house on
our response
to coronavirus we're prioritizing jobs
businesses and public services
the furlough scheme support for the
self-employed
loans grants tax cuts and deferrals
as well as extra funding for schools
councils the nhs
charities culture and sport today's
figures confirm that taken together
we are providing 280 billion pounds
to get our country through coronavirus
next year to fund our programs
on testing ppe vaccines
we are allocating an initial 18
billion pounds to protect the public
services
most affected by coronavirus we are also
providing
3 billion pounds to support nhs recovery
allowing them to carry out up to a
million checks scans and operations
over two billion pounds to keep our
transport arteries open
subsidizing our rail networks over three
billion pounds
to local councils and an extra 250
million pounds
to help end rough sleeping and while
much of our coronavirus response is uk
wide
the government is also providing 2.6
billion pounds to support the devolved
administrations
in scotland wales and northern ireland
taken together next year public services
funding
to tackle coronavirus will total
55 billion pounds
speaker let me turn to the ovr's
economic forecasts
and can i thank the new chair richard
hughes and his whole team
for their work the obr forecast
the economy will contract this year by
11.3
percent the largest fall in output
for more than 300 years as the
restrictions are eased
they expect the economy to start
recovering growing by five and a half
percent next year
6.6 in 2022
then 2.3 1.7 and 1.8
in the following years even with growth
returning
our economic output is not expected to
return
to pre-crisis levels until the fourth
quarter
of 2022 and the economic damage
is likely to be lasting long-term
scarring means
in 2025 the economy will be around
three percent smaller than expected in
the march budget
mr speaker the economic impact of
coronavirus and the action we've taken
in response
means that there has been a significant
but necessary increase
in our borrowing and debt the uk
is forecast to borrow a total of 394
billion pounds
this year equivalent to 19
of gdp the highest recorded level of
borrowing
in our peacetime history
borrowing falls to 164 billion pounds
next year
105 billion pounds in 2223
then remains at around 100 billion
pounds
four percent of gdp for the remainder
of the forecast underlying debt
after removing the temporary effect of
the bank of england's asset purchases
is forecast to be 91.9 of gdp this year
and due to elevated borrowing levels
and a forecast persistent current
deficit
underlying debt is forecast to continue
rising in
every year reaching 97.5
of gdp in 25 26.
high as these costs are the cost of
inaction
would have been far higher but this
situation is clearly unsustainable
over the medium term we could only act
in the way we have
because we came into this crisis with
strong public finances
and we have a responsibility once the
economy recovers
to return to a sustainable fiscal
position mr speaker
this is an economic emergency that's why
we have taken
and continue to take extraordinary
measures to protect people's jobs
and incomes and it is clear
those measures are making a difference
the obr now state as the bank of england
and imf already have
that our economic response has protected
jobs
supported incomes and helped businesses
stay afloat
they've said today that business
insolvencies have fallen
compared to last year and the latest
data
shows the uk's unemployment rate is
lower
than italy france spain canada
and the united states and we're doing
more
to build on our plan for jobs
i'm announcing today nearly 3 billion
pounds
for my right honourable friend the work
and pension secretary
to deliver a new three-year restart
program
to help over a million people who've
been unemployed for over a year
find new work
but i've always said we cannot
protect every job despite the
extraordinary support we've provided
the obr expects unemployment to rise to
a peak in the second quarter of next
year
of seven and a half percent 2.6
million people unemployment is then
forecast to fall in every year
reaching 4.4 by the end of 2024.
mr speaker today's statistics
remind us of something else coronavirus
has deepened the disparity
between public and private sector wages
in the six months to september private
sector wages
fell by nearly one percent compared to
last year
over the same period public sector wages
rose by nearly four percent
and unlike workers in the private sector
who have lost jobs
been furloughed seen wages cut and hours
reduced
the public sector has not
in such a difficult context for the
private sector
especially for those people working in
sectors like
retail hospitality and leisure i cannot
justify
a significant across-the-board pay
increase
for all public sector workers instead
we are targeting our resources at those
who need it most to protect public
sector jobs at this time of crisis
and ensure fairness between the public
and private sectors
i'm taking three steps today
first taking account of the pay review
body's advice
we will provide a pay rise to over a
million
nurses doctors and others working in the
nhs
second to protect jobs
pay rises in the rest of the public
sector
will be paused next year
but third we will protect those
on lower incomes the 2.1 million
public sector workers who earn below the
median wage of 24 000 pounds
will be guaranteed a pay rise of at
least
250 pounds what this means mr speaker
is that while the government is making
the difficult decision to control public
sector pay
the majority of public sector workers
will see their pay increase next year
and we want to do more for the lowest
paid
we are accepting in full the
recommendations
of the low pay commission to increase
the national living wage
by 2.2 percent to 8 pounds 91
an hour to extend this rate to those
age 23 and over and to increase
the national minimum wage rates as well
taken together these minimum wage
increases
will likely benefit around two million
people
a full-time worker on the national
living wage will see their annual
earnings
increase by 345 pounds
next year and compared to 2016
when the policy was first introduced
that's a pay rise
of over 4 000 pounds
mr speaker these are difficult and
uncertain economic times
so it is right that our immediate
priority is to protect people's health
and their jobs but we need to look
beyond
today's spending review delivers
stronger public
services our second priority
and before i turn to the details let me
thank the whole treasury team
and especially my right honourable
friend the chief secretary
for their dedication and hard work in
preparing today's spending review
next year total departmental spending
will be 540 billion pounds
over this year and next day today
departmental spending will rise in real
terms
by 3.8 the fastest
growth rate in 15 years in cash terms
day day-to-day departmental budgets will
increase next year
by 14.8 billion pounds
and mr speaker this is a spending review
for the whole of the united kingdom
through the barnet formula today's
decisions increased scottish government
funding
by 2.4 billion pounds welsh government
by 1.3 billion pounds and 0.9 billion
pounds
for the northern ireland executive the
whole of the united kingdom will benefit
from the uk shared prosperity fund and
over time
we will ramp up funding so that total
domestic
uk-wide funding will at least match
eu receipts on average reaching around
one
and a half billion pounds a year
to help local areas prepare for the
introduction of the uk spf
next year we will provide funding for
communities
to pilot programs and new approaches
and we will accelerate four city and
growth deals in scotland
helping tay cities borderlands murray
and the scottish islands create jobs and
prosperity
in their areas mr speaker our public
spending plans
deliver on the priorities of the british
people
today's spending review honors our
historic multi-year commitment to the
nhs
next year the core health budget will
grow by 6.6 billion pounds
allowing us to deliver 50 000 more
nurses and 50 million more general
practice appointments
we're increasing capital investment by
2.3 billion pounds
to invest in new technologies to improve
patient and staff experience
replace aging diagnostic machines like
mri and ct scanners
and fund the biggest hospital building
program in a generation
building 40 new hospitals and upgrading
70 more we're investing in social care
too
today's settlement allows local
authorities to
increase their core spending power by
four and a half
percent local authorities will have
extra flexibility
for council tax and adult social care
precept
which together with 300 million pounds
of new grant funding gives them access
to an extra billion pounds
to fund social care and this is on top
of the extra billion pound social care
grant we provided this year
which i can confirm will be maintained
to provide a better education for our
children we're also getting on with our
three-year investment plan for schools
will increase the school's budget next
year by 2.2 billion pounds
well on the way to delivering our
commitment of an extra 7.1 billion
pounds
by 2223 every pupil in the country
will see a year-on-year funding increase
of at least
two percent and we're funding the prime
minister's commitment
to rebuild 500 schools over the next
decade
and we're also committed to boosting
skills with 291 million pounds
to pay for more young people to go into
further education
one and a half billion pounds to rebuild
colleges
375 million pounds to deliver the prime
minister's lifetime skills guarantee
and extend traineeships sector-based
work academies
and the national career service as well
as improving the way the apprenticeship
system
works for businesses and we're also
making our streets safer next year
funding for the criminal justice system
will increase by over a billion pounds
we're providing more than 400 million
pounds to recruit
six thousand new police officers well on
track
to recruit twenty thousand and four
billion pounds
over four years to provide eighteen
thousand
new prison places new hospitals
better schools safer streets the british
people's priorities
are this government's priorities
mr speaker today's spending review
strengthens
the united kingdom's place in the world
this country has always and will always
be
open and outward looking leading
in solving the world's toughest problems
but during a domestic fiscal emergency
when we need to prioritize our limited
resources
on jobs and public services
sticking rigidly to spending 0.7 percent
of
our national income on overseas aid is
difficult to justify
to the british people especially
when we're seeing the highest peacetime
levels of borrowing
on record i have listened
with great respect to those who have
argued passionately
to retain this target but at a time of
unprecedented crisis government
must make tough choices
i want to reassure the house that we
will continue
to protect the world's poorest spending
the equivalent of 0.5
of our national income on overseas aid
in 2021
allocating 10 billion pounds at this
spending review
and our intention is to return
to 0.7 percent when the fiscal situation
allows based on the latest
oecd data the uk would remain
the second highest a donor in the g7
higher
than france italy japan canada
and the united states and 0.5
is also considerably more than the 29
countries
on the oecd's development assistance
committee
who averaged just 0.38
and overseas aid is of course only one
of the ways
we play our role in the world the prime
minister has announced over 24 billion
pounds of investment
in defense over the next four years the
biggest sustained increase
in 30 years allowing us to provide
security
not just for our country but around the
world
we're investing more in our extensive
diplomatic network
already one of the largest in the world
and providing
more funding for new trade deals
we should however judge our standing in
the world
not just by the money we spend but by
the causes we advance
and the values we defend
mr speaker if this spending review's
first priority
was getting the country through
coronavirus and it's second
with stronger public services then our
final priority
is to deliver our record investment
plans in infrastructure
capital spending next year will total
100 billion pounds
27 billion pounds more in real terms
than last year our plans deliver the
highest sustained level of public
investment
in more than 40 years once in a
generation plans
to deliver once in a generation returns
for our country
to build housing we're introducing a 7.1
billion pound national home building
fund
on top of our 12.2 billion affordable
homes program
will deliver faster broadband for over 5
million premises across the uk
better mobile connectivity with 4g
coverage across 95
of the country by 2025 the biggest ever
investment in new roads upgraded
railways new cycle lanes
and over 800 zero emission buses our
capital plans
will invest in the greener future we
promised delivering
the prime minister's 10-point plan for
climate change
we're making this country a scientific
superpower
with almost 15 billion pounds of funding
for research and development and we're
publishing today a comprehensive new
national
infrastructure strategy to help finance
our plans
i can also announce we will establish a
new
uk infrastructure bank headquartered in
the north of england
the bank will work with the private
sector to finance
major new investment projects across the
united kingdom
starting this spring
mr speaker i have one further
announcement to make
for many people the most powerful
barometer of economic success
is the change they see and the pride
they feel
in the places we call home
people want to be able to look around
their towns and villages
and say yes our community this place
is better off than it was five years ago
for too long our funding approach has
been complex
and ineffective and i want to change
that
today i'm announcing a new leveling up
fund
worth 4 billion pounds any local area
will be able to bid directly to fund
local projects
the fund will be managed jointly between
the treasury the department for
transportation
and the ministry for housing communities
and local government
taking a new holistic place-based
approach to the needs of local areas
projects must have real impact they must
be delivered
within this parliament and they must
command local support
including from their member of
parliament
this is about funding the infrastructure
of everyday life a new bypass
upgraded railway stations less traffic
more libraries museums and galleries
better high streets and town centres
this government
is funding the things people want and
places
need mr speaker
today i've announced huge investment
in jobs public services
and infrastructure and yet
i cannot deny numbers alone can ring
hollow
they stand testament to our commitment
to create a better nation
but on their own they are not enough
to create one when asked what our vision
for the future of this country is
we cannot point to a shopping list of
announcements and feel the job is done
so as we invest billions
in research and development we're also
introducing a new immigration system
ensuring the best and brightest from
around the world come here to learn
innovate and create as we invest
billions in the building of new homes
we're also
simplifying our planning system to
ensure beautiful homes are built where
they are needed most
as we invest billions in the security of
this country
we're also defending free speech and
democratic rule
proving our values are more than just
words
and as we invest billions in public
services
we're also protecting the wages of those
on the lowest incomes and supporting
jobs
because good work remains the most
rewarding
and sustainable path to prosperity
the spending review announced today sets
us on a path
to deal with the material matters of
government
and it is a clear statement of our
priorities
but encouraging the individual and
community brilliance on which a thriving
society depends
remains as ever a work unfinished
we in government can set the direction
better schools
more homes stronger defense safer
streets green energy
technological development improved rail
enhanced roads
all investments that will create jobs
and give every person
in this country the chance to meet their
potential
but it is the individual the family
and the community that must become
stronger
healthier and happier as a result
this is the true measure of our success
the spending announced today is
secondary
to the courage wisdom kindness
and creativity it unleashes these
are the incalculable but essential parts
of our future
and they cannot be mandated or
distributed by government
these things must come from each of us
and be shared freely because the future
this better country is a common endeavor
today government has funded the
priorities of the british people
and now the job of delivering them
begins
mr speaker i commend this statement to
the house
[Music]
here it's been a very important step to
people while it's run
much longer which was agreed with the
chance and i think it's so important
obviously i've respectedly divided the
time up to give an increase
to the other parts as well show the
chance of the exchequer at least
thank you very much mr speaker this
spending review
was a moment for the chancellor to take
the responsible choices
our country needs it was an opportunity
to protect
key workers secure the economy and
recover jobs
in every part of our country
during this crisis we've seen who's
taken
responsibility community health workers
working round the clock
to keep us all safe the teachers who
kept working
so key workers could too
the delivery drivers and shop staff who
made sure we had critical
food supplies earlier this year
the chancellor stood on his doorstep and
clapped
for key workers today his government
institutes a pay freeze
for many of them this takes a
sledgehammer
to consumer confidence firefighters
police officers and teachers will know
their spending power is going down
so they will spend less in our small
businesses and on our high streets
they will spend less in our private
sector
many key workers who willingly took on
so much responsibility
during this crisis are now being forced
to tighten their belts now
not in the medium term to which the
chancellor refers
now in contrast there's been a bonanza
for those who have won contracts from
this government
companies with political connections
have been at
10 times more likely to win
government contracts so many businesses
have worked
tirelessly through this pandemic to
support local communities
keep critical supplies going and to
produce
drugs and vaccines at cost price in
astrozenica's case
working with some of our country's best
scientists
but in its response to this pandemic the
conservative government has wasted and
mismanaged public finances
on an industrial scale 130
million pounds to a conservative donor
for testing kits
that were unsafe 150 million pounds
for face masks and 700 million on
coveralls
that couldn't be used a 12 billion pound
hit
to our economy because the more
effective shorter circuit breaker
was blocked and a lengthier more
expensive lockdown put in place
instead 12 billion pounds so far
spent on a test and trace system that is
still
not working and today news
of 10 billion pounds in additional
costs for ppe at least partly down to
the conservatives lack
of pre-pandemic planning this waste and
mismanagement
is part of a longer-term pattern showing
that claims today around leveling up
simply don't match the evidence
hospitals
in liverpool and sandwell left unbuilt
over deadline by
years and over budget by hundreds of
millions of pounds
not a single starter home built despite
almost 200 million pounds being spent
northern powerhouse rail still not even
approved
six years after being announced
the court's modernization program three
years behind schedule
letting victims down up and down this
country
people in the north more likely to have
been made redundant
during this crisis holding everything
else equal
photo calls aren't enough we need
delivery like liam burns promotion of
green manufacturing in the west midlands
and the work of labour mayors and
councils across the country
and we need a government in westminster
that takes its responsibility towards
all four nations seriously
that means informing the finance
minister of northern ireland
about the shorter time scale for this
spending review
ahead of time and fulfilling the new
decade new approach commitments
it means doing the right thing by the
people of wales
to repair flood damage and make safe
legacy coal tips
it means ending the barney between
westminster and hollywood
and instead working together in
partnership
to protect jobs and livelihoods and it
means a shared prosperity fund which is
effective
because it's delivered not on the whim
of conservative ministers
but from our devolved governments and
our regions
the levelling up fund the chancellor
just
announced his rabbit out of the hat
yet again involves
just as with the beeching's reopening
program going to ministers
and begging for support for their areas
rather than that change
being driven from local communities so
much mr speaker
for taking back control this is about
the center
handing over support in a very
top-down manner now labour has been
clear
about the responsible choices we wanted
the chancellor
to make today to recover jobs retrain
workers
and rebuild businesses to recover jobs
labour called for 30 billion pounds of
capital spending
accelerated into the next 18 months
focused on green initiatives supporting
400 000 jobs
and bringing us in line with countries
like france
and germany this government's ambition
is for half that number of new jobs
to retrain workers we needed an
emergency program to support people back
into work but kickstart has been slow to
get started
and the skills offer for those over 25
won't start
until april the chancellor said at the
beginning of his speech
that our economic emergency has only
just
begun try telling that to people who've
been out of work
since march and restart
announced today must meet three key
tests
to be effective it should help people
who need it most
not cherry pick it should be up and
running as soon as possible
yet it appears only a fraction of
restart funding will be available next
year
and restart must involve local actors
who know their communities
not be imposed from whites hall and of
course
job search support ultimately only works
if sufficient new jobs actually exist
that's why we needed
ambitious action to boost our economy
and to support our
businesses to rebuild business we called
for a national
investment bank and i welcome the
announcement of a new
uk infrastructure bank having lost
valuable years
since the green investment bank was sold
off
now the chancellor must boost its
firepower
and he must deliver on his department's
responsibility
for the drive to net zero we've known
since the stern reports that the climate
crisis
is the biggest long-term threat to our
economy
yet far too often this spending review
locks us into a path
that will make the transition to net
zero harder
not easier locking our economy out of
the green
jobs of the future to rebuild business
the chancellor also needs to listen to
business
we're less than a week from the end of
the lockdown yet we've heard nothing
about whether extra support will be
provided through the additional
restriction support grant
for areas subject once again to tough
restrictions
and the chancellor is still threatening
employers with an increased contribution
to furlough in january at the worst
possible time
for increasing and building confidence
mr speaker in less than 40 days were due
to leave
the transition period yet the chancellor
didn't even
mention that in his speech there's still
no trade deal
so does the chancellor truly believe
that his government
is prepared and that he's done enough to
help those businesses
that will be heavily affected will he
take responsible action
also to help those excluded from
government support
why is he still refusing to make the
speedy fixes to universal credit
labor has advocated which would aid the
self-employed
and why won't he provide families with
certainty
by ensuring the increase in universal
credit is continued
beyond april the imf has made clear
time and time again that now would be
the worst time to slam on the brakes
and put the car into reverse they've
called for a meaningful
additional push from our government to
maintain fiscal support
until the recovery is on a sound footing
the uk's gdp
is 10 smaller now than it was at the end
of last year
we've seen the worst downturn in the g7
we needed ambitious action today to
stimulate growth
and maintain demand and we needed this
government to take responsibility
for the real reasons why people in
communities are being held back
up and down our country over the last 10
years
child has risen by six hundred thousand
we've had the worst decade for pay
growth in eight
generations the cost of child care has
risen twice
as fast as wages the number of young
apprentices
has plummeted last quarter we saw the
highest level of redundancies
on record social care is an increasing
crisis
and despite his party's manifesto
promising a long-term solution
we're still waiting in the press it was
trailed that the chancellor
would be moving 20 000 jobs out of
london
yet cuts to local authorities over the
last 10 years
have seen 240 000 jobs
lost 12 times that figure with the
hardest tech communities often those in
the north
midlands and south west today the
chancellor could have matched his
government's promise
to do whatever is necessary to support
local authorities through this crisis
he did not and yet again he showed his
government's lack of confidence
in its own measures by failing to
provide an equality
impact assessment mr speaker the measure
of this government
won't be the number of press releases
issued during this crisis
or the number of pictures it published
on instagram it will be the responsible
action
it took or didn't take for the sake of
our country
next year the eyes of the world will be
on the uk
as we assume the presidency of the g7
and of the un security council
and host the cop 26 summit yet now is
the time
the chancellor has turned his back on
the world's poorest by cutting
international aid it's in britain's
national interest
to lay the foundations for economic
growth across the world
no wonder many british businesses have
condemned his move
and businesses have been more and more
vocal
about the problems with this
government's last minute approach always
one step behind
when we need to plan responsibly for the
future
we must learn the lessons from previous
failures and ensure that the next
challenge
the rollout of the vaccine is dealt with
as efficiently
effectively and speedily as possible
next time mr speaker we need a
comprehensive spending review
which takes responsible choices to build
a future for our country is the best
place in the world to grow up in
and the best place to grow old in people
should have opportunities on their
doorstep
not at the other end of the country
everywhere in the uk
should feel like a good place to set up
home that's what
the chancellor must deliver
thank you uh mr speaker and i'll address
all the points made by the honourable
member in term but i think it's
important to know up front that despite
her criticisms
i think there is in fact actually a lot
that both she and her colleagues
on that side of the house should welcome
more funding for public services
a pay increase for nhs workers support
for those on the lowest incomes
a once in a generation investment in
infrastructure a multi-billion pound
commitment
to support those looking for work a new
skilled building
schools building program and the prime
minister's ten point plan i could
go on mr speaker so whilst it's right
that i believe the honourable lady
should provide
challenge i think that even if she
doesn't
the british people would judge this
spending review
as a reflection of their priorities
protecting jobs defeating coronavirus
strengthening our public services and
upgrading our infrastructure
if there is any politics here at all mr
speaker then surely
it is unifying and deep down i think
that she will recognize that
to address the specific points mr
speaker the honourable lady asked about
pay
and about the importance of consumption
and i agree of course
there is an impact on consumption from
pay and she will know that the marginal
propensity consumer is obviously
greater the lower the income spectrum
you go which is why in particular
we have protected the incomes of those
on the lower incomes
anyone in the public sector earning less
than the uk median salary of 24 000
pounds
will receive a pay rise of 250 pounds or
more
taken with all the other things we've
done including giving a pay rise for
those who work in the nhs
this will mean that the majority of
public sector workers next year
will see an increase in their pay also
pay progression
promotions all of that will also carry
on mr speaker we've increased wages
for those on the national living wage an
extra 345 pounds a year
for those as the wage rate goes up to
8.9
pounds 88 pounds 91 and that again will
help drive
consumption uh she talked about delivery
rightly we believe very firmly
in making sure that we can deliver the
change that we promised the british
people
my ronald friend the chief secretary and
i chair something called project speed
which is already delivering benefits mr
speaker
with plans for the landmark a66 upgrade
shortened in time reduced in costs so we
can get on with delivering
what the people want in on time on
budget
and uh and making a difference in their
communities
she asked about the leveling up fund and
i thought rather bizarrely seemed to
suggest
that local members of parliament were
not a good reflection
on their local communities and able to
articulate the local needs of their
communities
but i would say to colleagues on that
side of the house there will be more
than
that i'm more than happy to hear from
them and their local areas
about the needs that they need met
because this government will meet the
needs of local communities up and down
this country
mr speaker she talked about support for
businesses and chronovirus
it's because we've already put in place
the support
uh through this winter period mr speaker
the local restrictions grants that we
announced a while ago
are paid monthly and they work if your
business has been closed you will
receive a grant of up to 3 000 pounds
per month
depending on your rateable value if you
are a hospitality or leisure or
accommodation business in a tier 2 area
where obviously the restrictions have an
impact on your ability you will receive
a grant of 70
of that value up to 2 000 pounds as well
100 pounds as well and mr speaker those
amounts mean
that the business can help cover the
fixed costs of rent they of course have
access
to the furlough scheme right the way
through the winter and that comes on top
of the other recent support announcement
businesses today
i announced major reforms the way that
the apprenticeship system works
giving businesses what they have long
asked for the flexibility to spend
unused apprenticeship levy funds down
the supply chain with smes
the ability to front load payments for
training that they've asked for
and we're also looking at ways to
introduce even more flexibility for some
professions
we also recently mr speaker just
announced an extension of the annual
investment allowance for a further year
up to a million pounds
giving 98 of small and medium-sized
businesses
the ability to write off investments in
full next year
which will help drive their recovery um
she she talked about welfare
uh mr speaker and again i i would stand
proud of this government and previous
conservative government's record on this
issue
since 2000 since 2010 hundreds of
thousands of fewer people in absolute
poverty several hundred thousand
children fewer living in workless
households
income inequality lower coming into this
crisis than it was
when we first came in to office but mr
speaker this government compared
cares greatly about those who are most
vulnerable
we have demonstrated that during this
crisis by the support that we have put
in place
the evidence shows that those on the
lowest incomes
have been protected the most by this
conservative
government and that doesn't stop mr
speaker
the temporary uplift and universal
credit runs all the way through to next
spring providing security for those
families
of course we will look when we come to
next spring
at the best way to support people to
support their families
when we have a better sense of where the
economy is where we are with this virus
but we are providing extra support for
next year mr speaker
670 million pounds to help those
struggling families meet their council
tax bills worth about 150 pounds each
for three and a half
families up and down the country we have
also
said that we will maintain the billion
pound increase
in the local housing allowance that we
instituted this year
into next year providing support for
many millions of families
and also mr speaker we are making
available further funds
as the house knows to provide extra
support for food and meals for children
throughout the holidays
of next year she talked about support
for local authorities
perhaps uh she hasn't seen yet in the
dock and that's fair enough we announced
three
over three and a half billion pounds of
extra support for local authorities next
year specifically
to deal with coronavirus that comes on
top of their core spending power
increasing at decade level highs of four
and a half percent
that three and a half billion pounds is
there to help meet the shortfall
in sales fees and charges help to meet
the unrecoverable losses and business
rates and council tax that they've
experienced this year
and a billion and a half pounds for
general pressures let no one say that we
are not standing behind our local
authorities at this difficult
time mr speaker and and and finally
she asked about green and i think mr
speaker she compared
us to france and germany and questioned
us this government and the prime
minister's ambition we'll let her
let me say this about our plans our
plans i believe
are amongst the most comprehensive and
most ambitious
of any developed economy she talked
about france and germany
this country we are phasing out vehicles
in 2030 in france
it's 2040. in this country we're phasing
out coal in 2025.
in germany it's 2038. she talked about
the billions of pounds
that are spent by our friends i think
it's important when we make these
international comparisons that we do
understand the detail
mr speaker of what these other countries
promise in the german numbers they
include
the subsidies for renewables we do not
that happens separately
outside of our plan and is worth 44
billion pounds
mr speaker supporting renewable energy
in this country
through the tariff system which is what
germany alluded to they also in their
numbers include support for public
transport which we of course do not
because that is something that we do
uh just as a matter of ordinary course
of business i'm proud
of this conservative government's record
mr speaker the first major economy in
the world to legislate
for net zero the economy that has
decarbonized faster than
any other in the last 20 years this
conservative government will deliver the
prime minister's plans to get us the net
zero
and it's something that i hope the whole
house can welcome
and support so in conclusion mr speaker
this spending review
puts the full force of government behind
the priorities
of the british people and whilst we may
have many disagreements with the party
opposite
i am confident that in private at least
they will recognize the significant
investment we are making
to protect jobs strengthen our public
services
and improve our infrastructure we are
all
in this house answerable to the people
we represent
it is in their interests that we serve
today
we have made some difficult choices in
order to fulfill
that responsibility but with the
positive news
about the development of vaccines the
winter coved plan being announced by the
prime minister and the very real hope
that we are finally entering the final
stages of our fight against coronavirus
now is the time for us to come together
the british people have been through so
much this year
honorable and right honourable members
have been through so much this year
it is my belief that with this spending
review
and the fresh hope given by medical
advances
we can finally begin our recovery
now difficult decisions and all we must
deliver
on the priorities of the british people
let's head down to the south west with
the two of the
well the charts are they're giving a
very uh fulsome reply to analisa dodds
he said he'd address all her points and
certainly he compared
the uk favorably to european uh
countries on green pledges
uh i didn't detect him going into detail
about her question about the economic
impact of brexit
away from the chamber quite a lot of
reaction coming in this from
uh danny skrikandraja who is the
director of the uk chief executive
of oxfam angry statement about the
decision to cut
the aid spending from 0.7 to 0.5 percent
of
gdp he says cutting the uk's lifeline to
the world's poorest communities in the
midst of a global pandemic
will lead to tens of thousands of
otherwise preventable deaths
at a time when hundreds of millions of
people are hungry and decades of
progress against poverty is under threat
today's decision is a false economy
which diverts money from clean water and
medicines
to pay from bo for bombs and bullets and
of course a reference
uh to the increased defense spending
well we're going to get some analysis
of uh this statement in a moment
from our economic senator and cod ed
conway
also of course joined by our political
editor beth rigby
uh so beth uh ricky uh
rishi sunak has laid out uh his store
what are the main points for you
politically
well adam i mean he really did set the
scene didn't he with that opening
statement our health emergency
is not yet over and our economic one
has only just begun and then he ran
through quite
horrifying numbers and i won't go into
them in detail because that's
ed's job not mine but just to quickly
run through
the economy in big terms in real terms
he said would be three percent
smaller by 2025 than we'd expected it to
be
in the march budget and that sets the
scene really
for years of debate and discussion about
how we recover from kovid in the medium
term
what tax choices do we make what
spending choices
must we make but that all for another
day really as the chancellor
really was still in crisis mode wasn't
he in terms of
what he announced and politically what
was very
interesting in terms of the statement
was still this continued
uh commitment to spending he said in
real terms
uh spending next year will be 3.8
somewhere above inflation running at two
percent so overall
uh no return to austerity as we expected
uh the government still spending but
there were some difficult political
choices there
uh the public sector pay freeze for one
nhs workers were exempted as were public
sector workers
earning less than 24 000 pounds a year
they're going to get at least 250 pounds
extra but anneliese dots there the
shadow chance are very critical
of this measure saying why are you
giving people effectively a real terms
pay cut at a time where the economy
needs stimulating you want those workers
to go out and spend money and you're
cutting their pay
and you're also cutting them pay after a
very difficult year the chance of
justifying that
in terms of uh all of the private sector
job losses the other
uh big political hot potato there was
clearly
the overseas aid budget cutting it from
0.7
of gdp to 0.5 it was expected
it's deeply unpopular on the benches the
chancellor
defending it by saying i've listened to
this
i've listened with great respect to
those who've argued passionately to
retain this target
but this is a time of unprecedented
crisis and the government must make
tough choices he then said our intention
is to return to 0.7
when the fiscal situation allows i would
interpret that as
wriggle room no commitment that this is
just a one-year
program but where he took he gave back
uh to
local communities in the uk with this 4
billion pound
uh covered uh infrastructure sorry
leveling up fund as he called it where
local communities can bid uh for this
money so
taking money away from the overseas aid
budget but giving it back
to local communities in an attempt maybe
to appease
mps but also with that motto i guess
that charity begins at home but this
will be extremely
controversial but adam in the big
picture
of all of this the economic devastation
was laid bare there
as i said the economy three percent
smaller
ed will run you through uh all of the
terrifying figures around unemployment
and borrowing
and debt and the economy contracting by
11.3
per cent and once we're through this
health crisis that will be the story
that will dominate
our politics and our public debate for
years just like the financial crisis did
back in 2010 how do we get the
spending and the fiscal framework back
under control where do the tax cuts
sorry tax rises come from will we have
to have spending cuts
one other thing to leave you with the
manifesto
was explicit in protecting the overseas
age
aids budget the conservative manifesto
that has just gone
now what does that mean then in the
longer term for other
taxation policy promised by boris
johnson
you'll remember he promised in the
manifesto not to raise vat
not to raise in income sorry income tax
and not to raise
national insurance contributions that
was the holy trinity
of tax protection for voters if he can
let go of the overseed aids
commitment how much pressure will the
chance to put him on
in in the coming years to also uh review
those tax commitments
best thank you and let's just remind
ourselves of some of those figures
you're referring to
from the office for budget uh
responsibility
uh predicting that the economy this year
will contract by
an astonishing 11.3 percent that of
course
because of kovid that unemployment will
rise to 7.5 percent
2.6 million people
and also that the national debt by 2526
uh will be uh nearly all uh of uh the
annual economic activity account for um
representing
all economic activity 97
of gdp uh also the chancellor saying
that things won't get back
uh to anything like pre-covered normal
uh for another five years so all of that
ed conway really does underline what he
was saying
uh about the economic crisis
only just beginning it's it's really
stark and it's
it's it's hard to look at these numbers
with anything other than
some shock even though you know there's
no surprises here we knew that it was
going to be bad in fact actually when
you look at some of those numbers
whether it's
gdp and the amount that gdp is is going
to go down this year remember what we're
talking about when we talk about
gdp gross domestic product that's the
total amount of
income we're generating across the
economy and then shared between
uh everyone in the economy any fall in
that you know everyone talks about gdp
being a slightly kind of meaningless
number we'll actually know it's the best
measure of just how much
economic output we are producing each
year the best measure of just how
well-off people are
and a fall of that order we haven't seen
that since
1709 actually the number gdp
you know this statistic was only
invented in the kind of 1930s 1940s
so actually we've never seen anything
like this since the invention of it but
when statisticians have gone back and
looked through the
the data banks at various kind of pre uh
modern numbers including on agriculture
they reckon that 1709 there was a four
with about kind of 13
the great frost of 1709. this is the
worst single year that we've had for the
economy
since then which is i mean it's a
staggering number
but it is worth saying that number is a
little bit better than the obr
were expecting earlier on this year when
they first started to do these scenario
exercises looking at how the economy was
doing they were talking maybe about 13
percent off
and the same thing actually for
unemployment so you know 7.9.5
unemployment is not good news at all
however when you put it into perspective
that is actually
lower than we saw after financial crisis
when it was about 8.5
so it is worth just remembering that
while these some of these numbers look
very scary indeed and we haven't
got on to the national debt which as you
say is kind of getting up towards 100 of
gdp
while they do look very scary it could
have been worse
and also this is a very unusual time
it's a very unusual kind
of recession and the big question really
comes back to what beth was mentioning
and you mentioned a moment ago
adam that question of you know when the
return to normality
will be in the obr's numbers and it's
worth saying you know there's still a
lot of
insecurity about what's going on at the
moment and they've got various different
scenarios some of which presume that the
vaccinations are spread out relatively
quickly
others presume that test and trace
doesn't necessarily work
and when you look at those scenarios
there's still a big range of where we
could head
uh in the next year but the i mean i
think almost all of those scenarios
suggest that we're not heading back to
where we were before this
uh crisis hit uh for some years and
there could be a permanent
uh dent on the economy that's that's the
implication really
a permanent kind of three percent dent
on the economy over the course
of the next few decades potentially
that's what happened after the financial
crisis a lot of people thought well
we'll have a v-shape recovery we'll
bounce back to where we were
and also bounce back to where we would
have been that's the critical thing
where we would have been
had this never happened well in this
case it's going to take a while to
bounce back to where we are
and as for bouncing back to where we
would have been that may never happen
that being said we're talking about very
strong growth next year the strongest
growth that we've had
in decades as the economy starts to get
back to
hopefully something like normality and
as i say
pretty awful but not quite as bad as
some people had expected
and not necessarily a surprise no
surprises too in terms of the content
maybe just that that four billion pounds
leveling up fund and also the national
living wage some people thought that
that wasn't going to be
increased well it was increased and then
international aid i mean
you know as beth was saying that is
there's a big political story about that
there's also a kind of geopolitical
story about that the uk up until now was
the biggest
uh donor for international aid as a
percentage of gdp now it goes down to
become
the second biggest donor potentially now
that may not sound like much of a
difference but for lots of former
prime ministers and chancellors that's
not something you wanted to do given
it's not necessarily going to
save you all that much money and it's
going to cost you on the international
stage will voters agree with that
i suspect maybe not given that into you
know the question of
paying a lot more into international aid
when the uk is going through this
once-in-a-lifetime crisis
uh is something most people had had
questions about but yeah
pretty much as expected adam broadly
speaking scary numbers
not quite as scary as some of the four
figures we've talked about over the
course of the summer but now
it is there in black and white and
frankly you know someone who looks at
these charts
we will forever even after we maybe have
forgotten about covert 19
forever we will have these enormous dips
on all of the charts for the uk economy
whether it's about gdp
whether it's about the financial amounts
that the government is borrowing
it is there now in black and white the
impact of covert 19
has been greater than anything else in
any of our lifetimes
and that's why i think the chancellor is
very keen to keep on stimulating
the economy for the time being rather
than starting to raise taxes and do
big spending there was just a little bit
of spending discipline it's more like
the saint augustine
actually towards the public finances at
some point we're going to have to
start living within our means but for
the time being we're going to spend a
little bit more
ed the chancellor made quite a lot of
international comparisons uh
in his presentation not least of course
on the question of
uh uk foreign aid but what about the
overall
comparison of this economic emergency uh
have other recruitment economies other
g7 economies
uh eu economies been hit to the same
extent as the uk
i mean we're we're near the bottom but
frankly
you know most countries in europe that
have had covert 19
strike as badly as they have here in
this country are facing more or less the
same thing so you're talking about kind
of around 10
fall uh in gdp the uk may be a little
bit worse than most but spain is
probably a wee bit
worse but we'll have to wait and see
when the numbers come in basically
britain france spain italy
all in more or less the same camp
germany less badly affected because they
weren't as badly affected by
the virus and then the us despite being
very badly affected by the virus doing
better than pretty much
any major economy in europe and then
ironically china where this virus first
emerged they are pretty much the only
sizable economy in the world who are
going to see positive growth
this year so around the world this when
you kind of add it all up and when we
finally look at the numbers and it's
worth just saying
what we have from the obr today is still
technically a forecast but now at this
stage it's a forecast that is
pretty much it will be very unlikely if
it were
that far out from 11 it might be kind of
12 it might be
a 10 it might be a percentage point
beyond that but you know we're talking
now that we know that this is going to
be pretty much unprecedented
so it's the same mostly around uh the
develop well this is this is the
striking thing adam you know
it wasn't as if there was a trade-off
and you could just
you know allow the virus to affect your
economy and you would
uh you would have a potentially kind of
a good
economic outcome that doesn't seem to
have been the case most countries which
were
worst hit by the virus have also had the
worst economic hits
and the